what did you make of the whole gamestop
robin hood situation because you're
pretty vocal about that as well i am
i was stunned by it i lost 700 000 on
gamestop or not gamestop on amc but it
was the same like
they stopped the trading i i didn't even
know you could do that i i literally
didn't know
you could just say hey you can sell the
stock but you can't buy it
they eventually essentially tank the
stock price
and nobody will ever convince me if the
shoe was on the other foot
and you know the hedge funds and the
billionaires
were making a ton of money in a volatile
nature
that it would be stopped to be like oh
you guys are making too much
the little guy's getting killed but
that's what happened here
and do i think they're phone calls made
and things behind
closed doors and if you've seen the show
billions steve cohen even
is tied into these companies i think
there was shady stuff that went on and i
think the little guy got screwed for the
most part
to save billionaires and short squeeze
has been going on for a very very long
time this is essentially just a publicly
created short squeeze against people who
they thought were over leveraged in the
market right so yes
it is pretty amazing that that they shut
it down i interviewed
vlad he came on i think he see and
that's the ceo of robin hood
i think he sees me as a conduit to their
retail traders and they're trying to go
public and all this so
as a way to build trust back up is like
let me talk to dave and i'm no expert
on a lot of the things he was talking
about
i at first thought he was a criminal
i've changed to be
he was inadequately prepared and
borderline and competent
because the the the it was bubbling
like what was going on with gamestop and
amc it wasn't something that just you
snapped and it happened
it was over the course of a couple days
so to not be
ready for it that that to me is
incompetence but he brought up a fair
point
he's like we if we folded it would have
been
worse for our clients there came a point
where they were losing money on every
single trade because they'd actually
over leverage themselves in order to
fulfill the contract correct but i still
no one will ever convince me
if the rich guys are benefiting
nobody calls a timeout and says hold on
we're going to make sure that that i
don't believe
so along the same lines you a bitcoin
guy not a bitcoin guy i'm
i don't own any so i bought it at 11 000
and this and then i sold it quickly at
11 000 because i just couldn't wrap my
brain around i had the winklevoss twins
explaining to me what it was
they told me a story that sounded
cockamamie to me it's like elon musk is
mining gold
from outer space it's going to rain down
like i don't know what's going on here
i'm going to stick with things i know
the timing of me doing that
it went bananas i mean within a month of
me selling it
is when this rocket ship happened it's
interesting to me
the bitcoin the crypto people will taunt
me every single day about not being in
it
i love the way they handle social media
i think it's hilarious it's kind of my
vein
making the memes and all this stuff but
currently i'm not involved